a group of congressmen have floated a
proposal to create an
america first caucus in the house of
representatives
the caucus got the platform right here a
fairly modest endeavor to defend the
american nation to defend the quote
anglo-saxon political tradition and
notably to oppose
ugly architecture in federal buildings
sounds great to me sign me up right
well you understand some liberals
have called it racist now i know this
will come as a shock to you they never
do that sort of thing
and i know this is going to come as a
shock to you as well republican
leadership
went squishy caved they're running away
from it as fast as they can but you know
what
the anglo-saxon political tradition is a
wonderful thing
and ugly architecture is a very bad
thing and we will get into
all of the america first caucus policy
platform
even if the squishes won't i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from top 10 guy
one who says
he is now channeling dr fauci he says
americans will get their freedoms back
once i am no longer able to keep moving
the goal
posts right i think that's an insightful
read of dr fauci the problem is
he seems always to be able to move the
goal posts he's now even wading into
political matters that have not even the
most
tenuous relationship to so-called public
health
we will certainly get into all of that
but i i would say if you're if you're
hoping for
for the fouchy public health
dictatorship to let up anytime
soon i i would not hold my breath i
think it's far wiser
to be prepared and when you want to be
prepared you got to check out ready wise
no question about it
now is a better time than ever to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options ready-wise has many options such
as
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition
new adventure meals for hiking camping
and other outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you order online
you have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep
it is really important to be prepared
for you and your family in the event of
an emergency if the last year
more than a year has not taught you that
i don't know what will i can't help you
go get ready-wise today it's so simple
you just need four cups of water you can
you don't the water doesn't even need to
be hot in some cases you can prepare the
meals
right in the package that eliminates the
need for additional supplies
give yourself peace of mind this week my
listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com
when entering knowles 10 at checkout or
by calling 855-453-2945 ready wise is a
30 day no questions asked return policy
there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today that is readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code knowles 10 to get 10
off the america
first caucus policy platform here it is
i have this document
am i even allowed to possess this now
because i'm told it's
racist bigoted nativist that's a that's
a fun word nativist
awful terrible okay first of all we
begin with the name
america first lots of confusion about
this name america first they say this
refers
to white supremacists or something the
term america first
has existed in u.s politics for a very
very long time
and sure sometimes the phrase has been
uttered by unsavory characters
but much more often it's been uttered by
very savory characters i don't know that
seems strange to call people savory
the most famous iteration of america
first was the america first committee
which all the libs say was terrible and
racist and this is denatus
the america first committee going back
you know i guess almost a century now
80 years included william f buckley jr
included john f kennedy included gerald
ford two presidents well that's
can't be that bad huh potter stewart the
supreme court justice frank lloyd wright
speaking of
architecture lots and lots of people
this was a broadly isolationist group in
the united states
but as you could tell it cut across
party lines and
it was isolationist given a particular
time period
the phrase was then next made famous
again by
president donald trump you know he said
america first that's going to be
our credo that's going to be our
rallying cry all right
so what does the platform actually say
i'll v you know it's like an eight or
nine page platform i recommend you go
check it out yourselves but here are the
main points election fraud
is bad and republicans and democrats
have pointed out for years that there
are vulnerabilities to the election
process so we want
to implement a national voter id this is
extremely popular across all americans
including every demographic group
they want to look into curtailing mail
and voting yep they want to look into
fraud allegations from 2020 such as just
just to give an example
the least controversial example the
state of
pennsylvania violating its own state
constitution because the election
officials wanted to give an advantage to
democrats okay
makes perfect sense next bullet point
sovereignty
america was founded on the basis of
individual and state sovereignty
yup at the federal level it means we
need to expose deep state actors shrink
the regulatory state
and eliminate thousands of regulations
and indeed entire bureaucracies that's
just
basically conservative boilerplate
nothing controversial there
big tech big tech firms have become the
most powerful arbiters of information in
history and we've got to be able to do
something about that
starting with section 230 yep we've been
talking about that for
years at this point immigration the
america first caucus recognizes that our
country is more
than a mass of consumers or a series of
abstract ideas it's a nation with a
border and a culture yep
and here's the line that got them in
trouble with a common respect for
uniquely anglo-saxon political
traditions
yeah that's all true that's all true
we'll get into this anglo-saxon term
that the libs and the squishes are
trying to make a big deal over
but of course everyone agrees with that
point on immigration every conservative
agrees at that point
infrastructure they say they want
beautiful architecture not hideous
architecture
yup sign me up if that were the only
plank i would sign up to join this
this caucus foreign aid uh
they're generally opposed to foreign aid
um but it's not they're not even saying
we need a total
end to it they're just saying america
american tax dollars should not go
toward teaching gender studies in
pakistan
i i agree with that yep um so yeah
they're basically against foreign aid
but there's a little nuance there
national security uh they oppose the uh
liberal imperialists the sort of
wilsonian neoconservative yep a lot of
conservatives agree with that
coronavirus uh that this has been a big
power grab yep
trade we need to get fairer trade yep
totally makes sense environment uh we
we want to protect our environment um
but we don't want to you know make an
idol out of it yup makes sense energy
i mean this is all the
chinese communist party is bad american
education
should not be geared toward hating
america it's like totally
common sense stuff no conservative
could could disagree with very much of
this platform okay
but let's get to the most controversial
point the anglo-saxon political
tradition when i
read that i didn't bat an eye of course
of course america has an anglo-saxon
political tradition
that i say this as someone who derives
from the italians
the italian people did not found
plymouth colony the italian people
did not make up the continental congress
okay there's obviously
an english political tradition here but
this term anglo-saxon it's elicited lots
of
this is the dog whistle kevin mccarthy
the the
leader of the house the republican
leader in the house says it's a nativist
dog whistle
let's turn to an actual conservative
scalia
who not that long ago about 15 years ago
was was asked about the american
political tradition he used exactly the
same words
i want to bring you the brilliance the
wit
of anton and scalia in full diversity
alone
is is is not what makes a great nation i
mean
diversity alone makes some of the tribal
societies of the world that
that never quite make it such as some of
the
places in the middle east where we're
trying to
establish nationhood
as i said earlier it's it's part of our
tradition that everybody can be an
american
but there has been a common uh a a
common culture
yeah you don't have to belong to it but
there has been that what is it what is
it
what is it okay you you want to know
what it is number one
is there a bond is there a common
culture i think
let me tell you a story my junior year
college i studied in switzerland
and i used to get really annoyed when
the the french swiss professors i had
would refer constantly to les pay
anglo-sax the anglo-saxon countries
meaning england the united states
australia new zealand
okay canada i said you know
hey my name is scalia and i'm as
american as anybody look at this face is
this an anglo-saxon face
i had never been in england but at the
end of my year
i went to england and i felt at home
there is there is no doubt that american
culture
american common culture which nobody has
to belong to
originates with english culture and that
includes shakespeare it includes
nursery rhymes that we all know and that
we use as examples
that's our common culture and i think
the framers recognize
that uh and diversity is fine
but diversity does not make a nation
diversity does not make a nation
unity makes a nation not saying that
it's only
one particular type of people scalia
makes this point i could make the very
same point
we look a little swarthy don't we for
the anglo-saxon people and yet
this political tradition that we have is
anglo-saxon that's just the way that it
is
people now are quibbling over all these
sorts of little terms and they're saying
it's
that this is a pagan reference i
actually heard someone say that it was
the anglo-saxons refer to pagans and
saint ethelbert
would would firmly disagree with you i
think because he was the king of the
anglo-saxons converted to christianity
in the year 601 400 years more than 400
years before the norman conquest
it's all i think disingenuous stuff
it's all disingenuous stuff to deny the
real political tradition in this country
which
really does come from a specific place
from england and we want to pretend that
it doesn't and we want to pretend
that oh it's just all universal and it's
all just an idea floating in outer space
and you know america could just as
easily have come from
from the timbuktu political tradition as
it did from
the united kingdom and that just simply
is not true
moreover we have an america first caucus
here
which is explicitly not a racial
identitarian group
and it's being accused of being a racial
identitarian group
these the congressman who were pushing
paul gosar or some of the other people
but we do have racial identitarian
congressional caucuses we have the
congressional black caucus
congressional black caucus exclusively
racial
supports leftist policies totally okay
congressional hispanic caucus
exclusively racial supports leftist
policies
okay america first caucus
racially inclusive likes the actual
american political tradition and hates
ugly architecture
bigoted racist terrible you got to get
rid of it it's so disingenuous
i i just can't even take it anymore i
don't
i oppose racial hatred
because that's an offense against human
dignity
that's it so if i know that then i don't
need to worry about some disingenuous
leftists calling me a racist it just
doesn't bother me
but so many republican leaders it's like
this magical incantation
the minute you even suggest
they'll run they'll say i'll give you
whatever you want please i'm kevin
mccarthy please i'll disavow the entire
american political tradition
totally pathetic if you
want to protect yourself against all
sorts of terrible things
you gotta check out ring so much is
going on at our front doors
these days that is something that has
only gotten crazier for me because of my
cute little
bundle of joy my newborn son so you've
got people coming
and they're delivering all sorts of
stuff right they're delivering food
that's great you know and they're
delivering
toys and clothing and that's great and
then they're they're delivering people
you know sometimes some friends and
family okay
and then some maybe some in-laws and you
think maybe i want to
keep that door closed all i'm saying is
if you have a ring you can know who is
outside your door before you open that
door
you can be in your bedroom you can be at
the office you can be on a beach
on the other side of the world with a
ring you'll be able to know who is at
your doorstep even if they don't ring
the doorbell with motion detection
you'll get a notification go check it
out today
this really makes me feel safe when i
travel i know that sweet little elise
and cute little june
are all safe it also makes a great
housewarming present
do not wait get a special offer on the
ring welcome kid at ring.com
knowles comes with rings video doorbell
3 and chime pro
the perfect way to start your ring
experience go to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles
by the standards of today's republican
party
antonin scalia is a far-right fascist
nativist i don't know
i i have to get to the kevin mccarthy
line he says quote
the republican party is the party of
lincoln
and the party of more opportunity for
all americans not nativist
dog whistles
what does nativist mean what do
we hear that term a lot what does
nativist mean
it means that you have a
i suppose an inclination or a preference
or you have the interests of the people
born in this country
beyond over the people who are not born
in this country who want to come in here
does nate nativist i get it's not a
racial thing right we have people of all
sorts of races in in america
who are born here or native to america
it means that you think maybe we should
reduce
immigration a little bit it means maybe
you think we should not have a totally
open border
means maybe you think that if we take
two million foreigners in every single
year
way way way way more than anywhere else
in the world
way way way more than most americans
want polls show that
the majority of americans want to
dramatically reduce not just illegal
immigration but legal immigration too
if you think that if you are one of the
majority of americans of all races and
different political stripes
then you're a nativist according not to
some radical leftist according to kevin
mccarthy
the leader of the republican party with
republicans like this who needs
democrats
who needs democrats it's absolutely
pathetic gotta stop letting
the left dictate the terms of this
conversation
there is nothing wrong with advocating a
lower level of immigration as antonin
scalia says very well
diversity is a fine thing but it does
not make
a nation unity makes a nation
and if you want to bring other people in
i
suppose that's fine nations have
immigration generally western nations
have way more immigration than
non-western nations
and america has the most immigration of
all fine you want to bring some people
in
that's great but if you can't assimilate
them
then immigration is weakening your
nation
and that's that that's all there is to
it
what is that common bond it's what the
scalia and all those guys were debating
the common thread that holds america
together they say well it's not a people
it's not a is it a faith is it a is it a
language i don't increasingly we don't
even speak the same language
if we have nothing holding us together
then we're not a nation now we're not
even allowed to acknowledge
our actual political tradition they are
denying the
actual history of the united states and
of england for that matter
bad situation it's a crisis you might
call it even joe biden might call it a
crisis
joe biden has assiduously avoided
speaking to reporters really at all but
specifically on this issue of
immigration he's avoided the word crisis
he's now slipped a freudian slip for
uncle joe is when he accidentally says
what he means
joe referred to the crisis at the
southern border
how was the first word so he was walking
to his car
it's kind of hard to hear him with that
mask there it is though crisis
working on that crisis this is probably
why joe loves the mask so much is so
that people can't hear all of the
nonsense that he spouts
cruisers i heard crisis sorry sorry
buster of course it's a crisis at the
southern border
nobody thinks that's a good thing it's
bad for america frankly it's bad for the
people who are trying to pour over here
it's totally lawless it's
anti-democratic you're violating the
laws that were democratically enacted
it's wrong it's wrong to do that sort of
thing but if you say that i guess you're
a nativist
and that terrible to be a nativist
these words these words that people just
use that they throw around
that i don't think really have much
meaning at all
anymore and yet we live in such fear of
them
we're still we we're a country that
lives in neurotic fear that's why we're
all wearing these stupid masks even
a year later more than a year after 15
days to slow the spread
after we flattened the curve after we
found a cure after
most people have gotten the vaccine
virtually everyone has access to it
ron desantis made this point the other
day in florida
he was not wearing a mask his staffers
around him were not wearing a mask
he was asked about the lockdown rules
and the masks
he had a great answer if you get
immunized you ought to act immunized
my view is is if you get a vaccine
the vaccines are effective you're immune
and so act immune
if you tell people the opposite then gee
you know why
if it's not effective for them and it's
not going to change anything
then what's the point of going through
it doesn't
make much sense does it no and ron
desantis you've got to give this guy
credit he
he has opened up his state for
what a year now or something he opened
it up
basically before anybody else and stuck
to his guns on this and the state's done
very well it's done a lot better
than california though desantis was not
the first
republican leader to make this point uh
actually senator cruz just uh two or
three weeks ago
he did not wear a mask to this press
conference and a lot of people around
him were wearing those masks a lot of
republicans around him were wearing
those masks
and the reporters said you need to wear
your mask and he said i don't think so i
took the shot yeah when i'm talking to
the tv camera i'm not going to wear a
mask and all of us have been immunized
so does it make us feel better you're
welcome to
step away if you like
the whole point of a vaccine cdc
guidance
is what we're following yeah you're
welcome to step away
if you want but i've been immunized and
so i'm not going to wear that dumb mask
and now senator cruz just isn't wearing
it
anywhere on capitol hill and i think
that's absolutely terrific
where are the rest of the republican
leaders on this i just i
i don't get it i don't
get why the gop
would spend its time sniping right
and calling anybody who wants to reduce
immigration and have beautiful
architecture and acknowledge our
political tradition
call them nativists insinuate that
they're bigots
when you've got the left running rough
shot over our political tradition over
our liberties over our way of life
that's the wheat from the chaff you got
guys like cruz you got guys like
desantis
who stand firm and then you've got
people like kevin mccarthy i hope that
guy
changes his tune real fast because it's
pathetic
and he you know in the in the last
squish battle you had kevin mccarthy
versus liz cheney who's probably the
worst of the worst in the house of
representatives
and kevin mccarthy took the more
conservative position defended president
trump didn't snipe right all the time
against liz cheney but now mccarthy
seems to be running away
don't do it man it's not too late come
on you can grab your spine and stand
with the conservatives it's not too late
i'm not saying we've got to cast kevin
mccarthy into outer darkness but just
come on you know we talk a lot about
various gender reassignment surgery here
and
a fixing different appendages do it
you know that would be one good use of
those sort of sort of surgeries
the public health dictatorship
is not going anywhere it's not dr fauci
is totally honest about this i rarely
would say dr fauci is honest but he is
being honest at least about his
his desire to maintain
power dr fauci goes on tv people are
getting the vaccine they have access to
the vaccine
and he's asked how long do we have to
keep the masks on and he says well
you know just a little while longer why
does a vaccinated person have to wear a
mask
okay this is something that as we get
more information
it's going to be pulling back that you
won't have to but currently the reason
is
that when you get vaccinated you are
clearly diminishing
dramatically your risk of getting
infected that's one of the things we've
got to make sure
everybody understands you dramatically
diminish it
however what happens is that you might
get infected and get
absolutely no symptoms not know you're
infected
and then inadvertently go into a
situation with vulnerable people
and if you don't have a mask you might
inadvertently
infect them now there's a small risk of
that but it's there
there's a small risk of that but it
could happen and so wear the mask
sheep that's just what he keeps coming
back to
he is making it as clear as a dishonest
disingenuous bureaucrat can make it
that they're just not going to let up
they're just going to
impose their whims on you
forever forever because the principle
that we have granted to dr fauci and the
other high priests of progressivism
wearing the cassock of the lab coat is
that
look our constitutional liberties are
our american political tradition
that's all well and good until uh cough
breaks out and then all of a sudden
we have to give all of our power to
fouchy so even when fauci says
okay you could okay you can lit up a
little bit on the masks we're still
acknowledging that he has the power to
impose whatever rules he wants
because he and his wisdom recognizes
that
the most important thing in life is not
getting a cough
that is a political revolution ben
shapiro is going to be talking about
political revolutions today
on the real insurrection going on by the
way backstage is going to be back
tomorrow 7 pm eastern 4 p.m pacific
you know it's almost time for another
episode of candace this week's special
guest
is dana white president of the ultimate
fighting championship
which is the largest mma organization in
the world the show streams on fridays at
9 pm eastern 8 pm central only on
dailywire.com you can get 25 off a new
membership with code candace
get the audio podcast canvas on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcasts
if you need some candace owens in your
podcast feed look no further
head on over to apple podcasts or
spotify and subscribe today
be sure to leave a five-star review if
you like what you hear
we'll be back with a lot more
dr fauci says even if you've been
vaccinated you've got to keep your mask
on
because there's a very very
infinitesimally small chance
that even though you're immune to
coronavirus
you could carry it and infect somebody
else do you see the problem though with
his logic here
the vaccine is available to just about
everybody
we can all get the vaccine i have not
gotten the vaccine
many many of my friends have gotten the
vaccine
i have it's not that i have not gotten
the vaccine because
it's not available to me it is available
to me i've made a
calculation of my risk from the
coronavirus
the data and the science show i'm not
particularly at risk
so i just don't see any need to get it i
don't get the flu shot either
just i don't i don't worry about that
kind of thing too much
not it's not at the top of my priority
list okay
so dr fauci is now telling people that
even if they've gotten the vaccine they
need to wear a mask
to protect me because i haven't received
the vaccine
so i could still be infected if they're
carrying it
but i'm here to tell you dr fauci don't
do it on my account
don't do it for me buddy obviously i
don't
worry too much about that that's why i
haven't gotten the vaccine
so if the vaccine is available to
everybody this excuse that we've got to
continue to mask and lock down and
and upend our whole culture for the the
poor people who
who might be infected by it it falls
apart
the vaccine is available but he doesn't
want to let up on this
because he doesn't really care about our
political traditions and our political
liberties as he told
joy reid on msnbc the other night
congressman jordan mentioned
the people of ohio i care very much for
the people of ohio i don't want to see
them get sick or die because we have 560
000 americans that have died so far so
we're looking at it from different
perspectives i'm looking at it from a
public health perspective
and he was talking about the
infringement upon liberties
right now what we need to do is get this
pandemic behind us and we will do that
and it will not be an indefinite
period of time it will not be an
indefinite it'll be two weeks to
slow this bro whoops oh i forgot i
forget it's been a year
give me a break it won't be indefinite
it'll just be
however long i want it to be says dr
fauci
i i love too the way he poses this he
says
look it's just two different
perspectives jim jordan he's looking at
it from the perspective of
our of the law and civil liberties and
our political tradition and our whole
culture but i'm looking at it from the
perspective of
public health and it's such a demagogic
way to put it but what he's what he's
really saying fauci the reason he's
confident enough to say this
is that he knows that the american
political tradition and our liberties
are politically incorrect now and that
the cult of public health
is the ascendant religion in america the
cult of secular progressivism
where bureaucrats make all the rules for
us like eggheads such as dr fauci
make all the rules for us so he knows
that he's going to win that if it's
really just a battle
between those competing values but but i
don't think these are irreconcilable
values
i think that everything we do in life
involves some kind of risk
and the risk now from coronavirus with a
vaccine out there the risk now is
you could not find that risk with the
smallest
most high-powered microscope in the
entire world that is how infinitesimally
small
that risk is compared to plenty of other
things that we do all day long we get in
our cars we can walk across the street
and so in that prudential
judgment that risk calculation you've
got to make it's not even close
but dr fauci doesn't want to bring words
like prudence into this or
he doesn't want to acknowledge the
legitimacy of our political rights
in this country to govern ourselves
because look he's just trying to keep us
all safe
just trying to keep us all safe come on
man
it's not going to be indefinite you know
i got to tell you i'm looking around not
just in our country but countries around
the world it
it kind of looks like it's going to be
indefinite i'm looking up in
canada right now canada has essentially
declared
a public health regime
that will suspend all political rights
that in any way
contradict the caprices and whims
of the experts we've implemented the
strictest measures
in all of north america and the
difficult truth is
every public health measure we have left
comes with a massive cost to people
in their lives but we have never shied
away
from doing what's necessary we have made
the deliberate decision
to temporarily enhance police officers
authority for the duration of the
stay-at-home order
moving forward police will have the
authority to require
any individual who is not in a place of
resonance
to first provide their purpose for not
being at home
and provide their home address police
will also have the authority to stop
a vehicle to inquire about an
individual's reason
for leaving their residence and our
inspectors will also be ensuring that
those who
absolutely must come to work are
strictly following the public health
measures
for our employers and employees take
note
this is your last warning this
is the vision of the future
eggheads sitting in
ill-fitting suits with their glasses on
perfectly straight face saying hey
listen society
this is your last warning stay
imprisoned in your home
or we will arrest you because of
the cough that we said was only going to
be a worry for two weeks a year ago
if you do not comply with our every whim
your life will be ruined and your
your political order has already been
ruined because we now run the show
you think that can't happen here
this is it requires such a failure of
imagination
it requires such an ignorance of of not
just ancient history but really the last
12 months to believe
that what's going on in canada right now
cannot or even
likely will not come to the united
states
every political measure that we have
been
promised two weeks to slow the spread
just gotta flatten that curve
just gotta find the cure every single
promise
that these people have made to us they
have broken
every timeline they have given us
has failed it has only
gotten more intense more draconian
looking around at the anglo-saxon
peoples
you know england
australia new zealand canada united
states
look what look what our friends around
the anglosphere are doing
you don't think that's going to come
here the only way it doesn't come here
is if we fight back very hard if we
exert all the political
leverage that we have
it's already coming here it's or it's
actually already coming here did you did
you see what's coming out of oregon
right now
oregon is instituting a permanent
mask order michael wood who is the
administrator of the state's department
of occupational safety and health
said that it is necessary to
make a permanent quote permanent mask
rule
to keep current restrictions from
expiring
and michael wood said we're not out of
the woods yet
michael wood says that it's like it's so
on the nose it's so
cartoonish and yet that's what we're
getting oregon won't be
won't be the last state to try something
like this they might be the last state
to succeed but they might not be the
last
they very likely won't be the last day
to try something
i have spoken to putatively conservative
public health officials
who have i've said hey are we ever going
to get rid of these dumb masks
these filthy undignified masks
and they'll tell me well you know
michael look at coronavirus that'll go
away at a certain point but uh
you know look it's kind of gross can you
imagine we were all flying on airplanes
in the past without masks i can't
imagine that
i do that every time the stewardesses
aren't looking i take the mask down
yes i can imagine that because i'm a
human being and i don't want to muzzle
myself
because i have some modicum of
self-respect or at least respect
for our civilization
but you guys don't they they surely
don't have any
any respect for us so the left is going
to keep this up and try to make this
permanent
but don't don't think that that is going
to impose order on society
don't think that just because they're
going to exert a lot of control and lock
everybody down and in canada they're
going to threaten to arrest people if
they leave their homes
don't think that's going to make a more
orderly society it's going to make a
more chaotic society because while the
left locks down
law-abiding americans who respect our
political tradition
the left is also going to be permitting
and even encouraging
radicals and terrorists to go out in the
streets and commit
political violence that's exactly what
maxine waters just did
she instructed her followers
to riot if derek
chauvin the cop in minneapolis is not
convicted of murder
a a very difficult case to make there's
really no evidence he committed murder
and if he is not convicted maxine waters
says
burn the country down we have been
fighting for so many years for reform
reform reform and so
yes i would like to see the bill in
congress pass
on police reform but i know that the
right wing
the racist are opposed to it and i don't
know what's going to happen to it
but i know this we've got to stay in the
street
and we've got to we've got to demand
justice we're
looking for a guilty verdict we got to
stay on the street
uh and we've got to get more active
you've got to get more confrontational
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
there it is there's that confrontational
so maxine waters has already in the past
gotten in trouble for saying
she hasn't gotten in real trouble she's
just gotten a few bad headlines but she
never has actually held the consequence
she says when you see republicans when
you see people in this administration
you get in their face you mob on them
you get up on you go to their homes
right so she's already saying that
what happened last year
people who tend to support maxine waters
burned down the country
burned down private businesses burned
down government buildings
coast to coast and now maxine waters is
saying
we need to get more confrontational more
confrontational
what what is more confrontational than
that are you going to start releasing
biological weapons
are you going to start detonating nukes
hard to get more confrontational than
burning the country down
but that's what maxine waters is going
to call for and it's okay coronavirus
isn't going to spread during those riots
remember
that is what the liberal establishment
told us last year at the height of the
coronavirus panic
at the height of the hysteria a bunch of
radical leftists
led by black lives matter and antifa
went out into the streets and we were
told no that's fine that doesn't spread
coronavirus
actually it's good there was a letter
signed by over a thousand public public
health officials whatever that means
saying that that
if you went out to protest white
supremacy that was actually helping
the coronavirus mitigation effort
because you see
white supremacy is a lethal public
health threat
meaningless words that are merely used
as
instruments to exert one's will
totally unreasonable will the
anglo-saxon political tradition
tends to frown on street violence
the the anglo-saxon tradition from which
we get our political tradition it tends
to not look so kindly
on criminals running roughshod over the
law
in the streets maxine waters loves
criminals and street violence she loves
it she's encouraging it and she's been
encouraging it for a long time
which way you gonna go america those
those are the two choices
and it's it's not
even enough that the street criminal
side of the political question is
winning
it's that even the putatively
conservative republican leaders
are giving cover to the street violence
people and attacking their own side
that they'll you know they'll fight back
a little bit they'll try to against
the street violence people but really
they spend most of their energy going
after the people who want to conserve
that political tradition
the left is not even content
overthrowing
the whole political order
obviously what they want to do that
they've wanted to do that for a long
time they've written extensively about
that
the left wants to overthrow nature
itself there's a line that kennedy used
to quote
john f kennedy he would say this is
supposed to be a great inspiration he'd
say
some people see things that are and say
why i dream things that never were and
say
why not and he acknowledged he got this
line from george bernard shaw
what he didn't know is that the line
from shaw
comes from this play cycle back to
methuselah and the line actually comes
from the mouth of the serpent
tempting eve in the garden of eden the
line that shaw is giving
here that kennedy is quoting and a lot
of democrats have quoted since then
is the the language of the devil
we need total delusion we need to
embrace delusion well that is what the
left is doing
in human nature not just among
consenting adults but even among
children in a really disturbing case out
of texas
is a ten-year-old boy in texas he just
spoke before the texas state senate
he spoke to them regarding bill 1646
this is a bill
that acknowledges that it is child abuse
to chemically castrate children
and give them transsex hormones and
mutilate their bodies to make little
boys look more like little girls
so this little boy testifies before
the committee i
hesitated even to play this clip but
it's
it's really out there it's obviously
very very public already i'm gonna i'm
gonna blur
the kid's face and i'm not gonna refer
to the kid's name because
his mother is obviously abusing him
listen to his testimony to see how far
the country's gotten hello my name is
um i love ballet math science and
geology
i spend my free time with my cats
chickens face timing my friends and
dreaming of when i will finally meet
dolly parton
i do not like spending my free time
asking adults to make good choices
i've been having to explain myself since
i was
three or four years old
texas legislators have been attacking me
since pre-k
i am in fourth grade now
when it comes to bills that target trans
youth i immediately feel
angry it's been very scary and
overwhelming
it just it makes me sad that some
politicians use trans kids like me
to get votes from people who hate me
just because i exist
god made me god loves me for who i am
and
god does not make mistakes my mom has
been giving everything she has to stand
up for me
wow there and there it is you can listen
to the
you can listen to the rest of this if
you want to i suspect you don't
but you see that line my mom has been so
wonderful and there there it is
if you didn't already know from the
first part of this
that this poor little boy is being
horrifically abused by his mother
you get it there i don't believe that
the boy came up with these lines on his
own
of course of course he didn't and uh the
this rehearsed sort of caricature
of of what a woman is that he is
performing
i don't think this was an invention of
his own i think this was put into his
head obviously
the idea that he's been trying to
convince adults
of of reality since he was three years
old is obviously not true
three-year-olds don't convince anybody
of anything because three-year-olds
don't know anything because they're
they're very little is that does that
still count as a toddler
i don't know i'm not really familiar
with all the various designations
you're a very very little kid when
you're three years old and this
kid's pervert mother decided that she
wanted to have a little
daughter instead of a little son and so
she dressed him up like
a little daughter and now and now she
has
him trotted out protesting a law that
would prevent him from being mutilated
and castrated
that woman should be in prison she
should not be permitted
around children ever a just society
would would acknowledge that and codify
that into law
but we no longer have the ability to do
that
because on the left you've got them
actively pushing for this stuff
to trans the kids and castrate little
boys
and on the right the the best that we
can muster
is well you know not until he's 18.
well you know look i might not agree
with it but you know look it's freedom
you know well you know that's the that's
basically the best
that i'm not talking about you people
who listen to this show
i'm not talking about our friends here
who obviously have a more sophisticated
view of this
but i'm talking about the republican
leadership broadly speaking
they don't want to get into it they just
want to let the left run roughshod over
the culture even if it means mutilating
little boys freedom
we would have a freer country if that
kid's mother were in prison
and people like her we would have a
freer country if we recognized
limits to vice and licentiousness
and evil evil acts like castrating
little kids if we
if we took the freedom if we took the
the ability of these people to do these
sorts of things away from them
we would have a freer country because
liberty of course
requires limitations and licentiousness
and liberty are not
synonyms but we're not not allowed to
acknowledge limits anymore george w bush
former president george w bush just
came out he's got a new book out about
immigrants and he painted all these
pictures of immigrants
and he said america we've got to be
nicer to immigrants
do you want to be involved in the
immigration way in a way i don't want to
be prescriptive i don't want to you know
tell congress how to do this or that i
do want to say to congress
please put aside all the harsh rhetoric
about immigration
please put aside trying to score
political points on either side
i i hope i can help set a tone that is
more
respectful about the immigrant which
may lead to reform of the system
that's it you know and at this point the
host cuts in and says you know you
president bush you'll remember what you
used to say all these wonderful things
uh on immigration she plays the clip you
gave an
oval office address on immigration i did
these are not contradictory goals
america can be a lawful society
and a welcoming society at the same time
there it is and so there there is the
line right and he says that's right i
did
that's right you got me the meaning of
that of course
is that if you can be a lawful society
and a welcoming society what he's really
saying is
we can through the law massively expand
our immigration system
yes of course that's what democrats want
to do and that's what liberal
republicans want to do
but my question is can we be a lawful
society
and be a little bit less welcoming
that's what that's what the
immigration restrictionists want to do
because right now we take in about 2
million people a year
way way way way more than any other
country on earth way way way more than
we can handle you can see the culture
crumbling all around us
because of these problems of diversity
without any unity
diversity without any assimilation so
can we just maybe cool it down a little
bit
like the majority of americans want to
do are we allowed to do that and the
answer of course
according to these guys according to
george bush and according to the
democrats is no
some some democrats now are trying to
pass this around saying look even george
w
bush holds a liberal position yes the
bush family has represented the liberal
wing of the republican party
since 1952. you have jeb who says
illegal immigration is an act of love
you have george w bush who says he's a
compassionate conservative more
compassionate than whom
george h.w bush says he wants a kindler
gentler conservatism
kindler gentler than whom ronald reagan
was the implication
and prescott bush the the grandfather is
the
former u.s senator who was the first
treasurer of planned parenthood they've
always represented the liberal wing
can we have a conservative voice
anywhere anywhere the gop
anywhere this new caucus that some
congressman we're going to make
can we have it anywhere in this country
i hope so i think we can take our
political rights back
in our political tradition which derives
from an anglo-saxon tradition
i don't think that it is inevitable that
we be governed
by sort of neo-liberal progressive
republicans like
george w bush or by progressive
technocrats like dr fauci i think
there is a chance that we can take our
political rights back
apply reason and govern ourselves
but who's going to support us in that
effort or are we perhaps going to have
to do it ourselves i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy board our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show